I have nothing against Frozen  convenience Foods I love me a quickie  meal but 250 calories of just noodles  and a few pieces of broccoli is Not  Gonna Fill Me Up so I'm going to show  you how to turn it into a hunger  crushing combo that will step one  put it in a bowl so that you feel a  little more refined  all right adding in some rotisserie  chicken I've got some extra steamed  veggies that I had cooked off from meal  prep gonna add a little nutritional  yeast  and some extra really good cheese  and then we fold in the cheese but how  how do you fold it all right we got lots  of fiber in our veg some protein in our  chicken and our nooch and some fats in  the extra cheese still tastes like the  early 2000s but  it's a step up Poppy